let's serve up some news
sunny side up okay there is a hairy
it may look petable it actually looks
like a really bad dirty wig
it's like a really dangerous bug and
they call
what it's called the puss caterpillar
nature
god you gotta tone it down poisonous
puss caterpillars
shake it off shake it off shake it up
let's not even talk about the murder
hornets
hey puss caterpillars enjoy the
spotlight well it lasts
20 20. wow
oh my god it's courtney from the
american doll collection from the 80s
hey courtney wait i'm sorry what was
that
oh you think i should get a nancy reagan
doll or that mattel should incorporate
that
you know i used to hang out with nancy
back in the 80s
yeah i did i did the just say no
campaign with her
until i just said yes our next story is
something i'm sure we've all noticed
chloe you know how sometimes like people
in long-term relationships start to look
alike even celebrities i mean these
pictures say at all here's seth meyers
and alexi
ash i mean they look like you know
alike um steph and aisha curry
absolutely just beautiful uh benedict
cumberbatch and sophie hunter
they yeah these this one dylan sprouse
and barbara paulvin
creepy it's like it's crazy they do look
like brother and sister
um jim parsons and todd spiwak
adorbs they both adorable i know my
cousins
they say that the idea that couples
start to look alike
is really a myth yahoo life reports that
researchers found that if a couple looks
alike it's because they started out that
way
in today's new york times megan the
stallion penned this
powerful op-ed called why i speak up
for black women and that comes after
another headline worthy project
offering support to women of color who
are pursuing their degrees
classy bougie busy
i love it megan oh my goodness i see a
fresh
baby and you sir looked just like
everybody that was friends with my
parents
growing up and i see doggies and
oh everybody looks so beautiful
[Music]
[Music]